Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. We are going through the 12 or 13 days of Christmas, if you like. And today, of course, is the 30th of December. And Dominic, we have two new anniversaries. I have chosen the Battle of Wakefield. So this is a good one. I like the Battle of Wakefield. Why do you like the Battle of Wakefield So this is a good one
感谢收听《历史余音》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验节目系列并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史余音》。我们正在度过所谓的圣诞十二日或十三日。而今天，毫无疑问，是 12 月 30 日。多米尼克，我们有两个新的历史纪念日。我选择了韦克菲尔德战役。所以这是一个很好的战役。我喜欢韦克菲尔德战役。你为什么喜欢韦克菲尔德战役？所以这是一个很好的战役
I like the Battle of Wakefield Why do you like the Battle of Wakefield? Do you want to tell people when it is? Yeah, it's a Wars of the Roses battle isn't it? It's the Do you know the date? It's the 30th of December 1460 Very good
我喜欢韦克菲尔德战役。你为什么喜欢韦克菲尔德战役？你想告诉大家这是什么时候发生的吗？是的，这是一场玫瑰战争中的战役，对吧？这是……你知道具体日期吗？是 1460 年 12 月 30 日。非常好。
What I knew was the 30th of December So it's Richard of York's last hurrah isn't it? Not much of a hurrah Richard of York gave battle in vain Which is the way you remember the colours of the rainbow. Oh, yes. Very good. I like that.
我知道的是 12 月 30 日。所以这是约克公爵理查的最后高光时刻，对吧？也算不上什么高光。约克公爵进行了一场注定失败的战斗。这就是你记忆彩虹颜色的方式。哦，是的。非常好。我喜欢这个。
Yeah. So I used to love the Wars of the Roses when I was a child, when I was about 11. Do you not any longer? I do, but I suppose I... You've grown out of it. I wouldn't say I've grown out of it. You've moved on to Jim Callaghan.
是的。所以我小时候，大约 11 岁的时候，特别喜欢玫瑰战争。你现在不迷了？我是，但我猜我……你已经过了那个年纪了。我不能说我已经过了那个年纪。你已经转向吉姆·卡拉汉了。
The trouble is that now I think of the Wars of the Roses, I struggle to see what it means beyond the kind of dynastic feuding. Just people killing each other. Yeah. See, I think it's pure Game of Thrones, sort of families feuding for the crown, but without any, there's no religious dimension, there's no, I find it hard to see any deeper kind of political significance
问题是，现在每当我想到玫瑰战争，除了王朝之间的血腥争斗之外，我很难看出它还有什么意义。不过就是人们互相残杀罢了。对。你看，我认为这纯粹就像《权力的游戏》，各大家族为了王冠而争斗，但却没有任何……没有宗教维度，我很难从中看到任何更深层次的政治意义。
other than, you know, cousin A wants to kill to kill Cousin B and get the throne. Well, I mean, there's further complication that that is how Shakespeare frames it. And Shakespeare's plays, Henry VI, part one, part two, part three, a crucial part, you know, I mean, crucially influence that sense of it. And then, of course, Richard III. But it's Shakespeare who creates the idea of the roses, isn't it? They pluck roses in the garden in Henry VI.
除了，你知道，表亲甲想杀了表亲乙以夺取王位。我的意思是，更复杂的是，莎士比亚就是这样构架它的。莎士比亚的戏剧《亨利六世》（上、中、下篇），至关重要地……你知道，我的意思是，对这种看法产生了关键性的影响。当然，还有《理查三世》。但正是莎士比亚创造了玫瑰的意象，不是吗？他们在《亨利六世》的花园里采摘玫瑰。
No, I think that's... Is that Holland's head? It's one of the chroniclers, I think. Yeah, so it's not contemporary. But Shakespeare's reworking of it is obviously being very influential. And you're right. I mean, it is basically dynastic politics, but it's also a blowback from the defeat of France.
不，我认为那是……那是霍林谢德吗？我想是某个编年史家写的。是的，所以它不是同时代的产物。但莎士比亚对它的改编显然影响深远。你是对的。我的意思是，这基本上是王朝政治，但它也是法国战败后的反噬。
Yeah, yeah. right i mean it is basically dynastic politics but it's also blowback from the defeat of france yeah yeah so it's it's um noblemen who've uh you know been doing well in france who suddenly lost all their territory and have to come back and throw their weight around in england there are lots of men at arms who uh you know seasoned fighters who are looking for basically a job and so it's a kind of you know it's just waiting to explode but it's also there's been a complete breakdown of central authority hasn't it because henry the sixth is too it's too godly all he cares about is praying and thinking about educational establishments he has a complete mental breakdown so 1453 absolute mental breakdown and so the kingdom needs a regent it needs a lord protector yeah and a further complication to this,
对，对。没错，我的意思是，这基本上是王朝政治，但它也是法国战败后的反噬。对，对。所以这是……嗯，一些在法国混得风生水起的贵族，突然失去了所有的领土，不得不回到英国作威作福。有大量的武装人员，呃，你知道的，身经百战的战士，基本上都在找工作，所以这是一种，你知道的，一触即发的局面。但同时，中央权威也彻底崩溃了，不是吗？因为亨利六世太……太虔诚了，他关心的只有祈祷和考虑教育机构。他彻底精神崩溃了，所以1453年绝对精神崩溃了，因此王国需要一个摄政王，需要一个摄政公爵。
and this is certainly something that for Shakespeare is very important, I think possibly less so actually in the 15th century, is the fact that the House of Lancaster, of which Henry is the third king, so the previous ones, Henry V and Henry IV, are usurpers. That probably wouldn't be so much of an issue Tom if you've been sane right I mean no absolutely got on with that absolutely but but um so uh Henry the
还有一个更复杂的情况，这对莎士比亚来说绝对是非常重要的，我想在 15 世纪可能没那么重要，那就是兰开斯特王朝——亨利是这个王朝的第三位国王，所以之前的国王亨利五世和亨利四世都是篡位者。汤姆，如果你一直神志清醒，这可能就不会成为太大的问题，对吧？我的意思是，不，绝对的，那就顺理成章了，绝对的。但是，但是……所以，呃，亨利四世废黜了理查二世，并夺取了王位；但爱德华三世还有其他各种后代，而且在这个故事里有非常多的国王，我是说，不可避免地，四处都是。其中之一就是约克理查。所以约克家族，他们也可以声称自己是爱德华三世的后代，就像亨利六世一样。于是问题开始冒出来：嗯，如果亨利能当国王，为什么我不能？
fourth had deposed Richard the second uh and seized the throne but there are various other descendants of um Edward the third and there's an awful lot of kings in this episode, I mean, per force, floating around. And one of them is Richard of York. So the family of York, they also can lay claim to a descent from Edward III, just as Henry VI can. And so the question starts to bubble up, well, if Henry's can be king, why can't I? Yeah.
如果亨利疯了，那我们为什么不让理查当我们的国王呢？他是一个能干的管理者，一个久经沙场的士兵，等等，等等。所以，当亨利六世精神崩溃时，理查被任命为摄政；但是——这挺有意思的——而且我很想核实一下这周围确切的每月周期。在亨利精神崩溃期间，安茹的玛格丽特生了一个儿子。所以在那个时间点之前，亨利还没有继承人。
And if Henry's mad, then why shouldn't we have Richard as our king when he's an able administrator and a proven soldier and yeah all these kinds of things yeah so um when Henry VI has his breakdown Richard is uh appointed law protector um but and this is kind of interesting um and I'd I'd be interested to kind of check the exact monthly cycles around this. During Henry's breakdown, Margaret of Anjou has a son. So until that point, Henry hadn't had an heir.
而且是个儿子。所以看起来兰开斯特王朝的血脉是有保障了。是的。这对约克公爵理查来说可不是什么好消息，你知道的，如果他想当国王的话。所以在18个月后，亨利六世恢复了理智。约克基本上对此很不高兴。还有其他各种贵族，其中最主要的是内维尔家族。也就是索尔兹伯里伯爵和他的儿子沃里克伯爵，后者后来成为了著名的“造王者”沃里克。
And it's a son. So it looks as though the line of descent for the House of Lancaster is secure. Yeah. Which is bad news for Richard of York, you know, if he wants to become king. So after 18 months, Henry VI recovers his sanity. York is basically cross about this. And there are various other noblemen, chief among them the Neville's. So that's the Earl of Salisbury and his son, the Earl of Warwick, who will become famous as Warwick the Kingmaker,
甚至还成为了一本瓢虫图书的主角。我太喜欢那本书了。所以那是对他真正的评价……对我来说，那是瓢虫图书的巅峰。里面纯粹就是打仗，别无其他。到处都是穿铠甲的人，在秋天的泥地里摔跤之类的情景。
subject of a Ladybird book, no less. I loved that book. So that's the real measure of his... That to me was the acme of the Ladybird books. It was just pure, nothing but fighting. Loads of people in armour, kind of wrestling in autumn, mud and things.
所以，在圣阿尔巴斯有一场大战。亨利六世被俘，约克让自己重新被任命为摄政。汤姆，我喜欢那场战役，因为它是一场很不寻常的中世纪战役，因为它发生在城市里，对吧？确实如此。
So, there's a big battle at St Albans. Henry VI is taken prisoner, and York gets himself reappointed as Lord Protector. I like that battle, Tom, because it's an unusual medieval battle because it happens in the city, doesn't it? It does, yes.
他们在街头奔跑厮杀，这在中世纪战役中是不多见的。非常刺激。从河边打起。这拍成 HBO 剧一定棒极了。我觉得《玫瑰战争》就是。我想已经拍过了，不是吗？嗯，里面还有龙。
They're running through the streets fighting, which you don't normally have in a medieval battle. Very exciting. Up from the river. Make a great HBO series. I think The Wars of the Roses. I think it already has done, hasn't it? Well, with dragons in there.
所以这是一个试图起草某种休战协议的尝试。但同样，它还是分崩离析了，因为很明显，安茹的玛格丽特、支持兰开斯特家族的人、约克理查的敌人、沃里克的敌人，对此并不满意。1459年，战争再次爆发。
Yeah. So that's an attempt to draw up a kind of truce. But again, it falls to pieces because obviously Margaret of Anjou, people backing the Lancastrians, the enemies of Richard the York, enemy of Warwick, not happy with that. And 1459, the war breaks out again.
这让约克和内维尔家族有点措手不及，他们逃到了拉德洛。你一定很熟悉，那里有一座非常棒的城堡，拉德洛城堡。所以他们在城堡里闲逛，结果在那里被逼入绝境。爆发了一场战斗，他们四处逃窜。因此，约克逃到了爱尔兰。
And it catches York and the Neville slightly by surprise they flee to Ludlow you must know well very good castle, Ludlow Castle so they hang out in the castle, they get cornered there there's a battle, they all flee in all directions so York flees to Ireland
内维尔家族和约克理查的儿子爱德华——一个身材高大健壮的小伙子。是的。未来的爱德华四世。他有点像年轻时的猫王，不是吗？他后来成了拉斯维加斯的胖猫王。是的。他们逃到了加来，而约克派则被宣布为叛国者。
the Neville's and Richard York's son Edward big strapping young lad. Yeah. Future Edward IV. He's sort of young Elvis isn't he? And he later will become fat Elvis in Las Vegas. Yeah. They flee to Calais and the Yorkists
但他们仍然逍遥法外。1460年，未来的爱德华四世和沃里克从加来登陆。是的。他们袭击了北安普顿的兰开斯特派。他们再次俘虏了亨利六世——他完全是个废物，只会四处游荡被俘虏，念念经什么的。约克公爵赶忙返回，前往伦敦。他进入伦敦并宣称拥有王位。他说：“我应该当国王。”
are declared traitors. But they're still on the loose. 1460 Edward, the future Edward IV and Warwick land from calais yeah um they attack the uh lycastrians at northampton once again they they capture henry the sixth he's absolutely useless and all he does is kind of wander around getting captured saying prayers and things um and duke of york rushes back goes to london he enters london and he he lays claim to the throne he says i should be
这引发了极糟糕的反响，甚至连他的盟友都觉得这……你知道的，你不能随随便便就去反对国王。这很奇怪，不是吗？这让人想起了你最喜欢的主题之一，也就是君权的神圣性。确实如此。他们不愿这么做，他们真心相信那些加冕誓言和种种涂油礼。
king and this goes down tremendously badly even even with his allies they they think this is a you know you can't just go around opposing kings like this that's strange isn't it that's a reminder of one of your favourite themes, which is the sacronator of kingship. It is. That they don't want to, they really believe in those kind of coronation oaths and all that anointing.
波涛汹涌的大海里的所有水，也无法洗掉受膏君王身上的圣油。这是莎士比亚的台词吗？这是理查二世说的。当然，你知道，事实证明它们确实洗得掉。但他大错特错了。所以这就是那种……但在这种情况下，嗯……我的意思是，理查被推翻了，因为他是个噩梦。人们对亨利保持忠诚，因为他无害。是的，他是个好人，完全无力应对局势。是的，他的树木……所以，所以他们……所以他们草拟了一个妥协方案，那就是亨利继续做国王，但瓦尔斯的爱德华——也就是玛格丽特在亨利发疯时生下的那个儿子——将被剥夺继承权；而且，呃，约克理查的儿子……这里有太多的爱德华和理查之类的人了，我希望大家能跟上这个世界，回头会有个测试……他将……他将成为继承人。所以基本上约克理查和他的儿子们将成为继承人。所以这将是约克家族和新的继承世系。玛格丽特显然对此暴跳如雷，绝对暴跳如雷。
Not all the waters in the rough-rood sea can wash the balm off an anointed king. Is that Shakespeare? It's Rich II saying that, which of course, you know, it actually turns out that they can. But he was quite wrong so that's the kind of but in this case um i i mean i richard is richard is toppled because
所有的兰开斯特党人……他们在北方发动了进攻，而那里当然是约克家族的大本营。所以他们径直扑向约克周围的所有领地。作为一个封建领主，其全部意义就在于保护你的领地和你的旗人。所以约克急忙赶去应对这个威胁，并带上了他的二儿子、 Rutland 伯爵埃德蒙。他们被困在韦克菲尔德郊外的桑德尔城堡里。他们寡不敌众。他们知道援军正在赶来。
he's a nightmare people stay loyal to henry because he's inoffensive yeah he's a nice guy he's completely out of his depth yeah his trees so so they they um so they they kind of draw up a compromise which is that henry will stay king but edward the prince of wales so the son that margaret fongue had had when he'd been mad will be dispossessed and um edward richard york's son there are a lot of edwards and richards and things i hope people are keeping up with the world there'll be a test um he he will he'll become the heir so basically richard york and his sons will will will be the heirs so that's going to be the yorkists and the new line of succession um and margaret
但出于某种原因，理查从约克发动了一次突围。没有人知道为什么会这样，对吧？这简直是一场混乱，不是吗？因为这不是……韦克菲尔德战役其实不像是阵地战，倒像是在树林里的一场群殴什么的。他跌跌撞撞地走出去，冲进了一个……是的，他有点像是被人伏击了。
obviously is livid absolutely livid about this um all the lancastrians um and they go on the attack in the north which of course is where York's heartlands are so they kind of zoom in on all his lands around York and the whole point of being a feudal lord is that you protect your lands your bannermen so York goes rushing up
关于到底发生了什么，有各种各样的说法：你知道的，他是没有意识到发生了什么吗？有人告诉他有人要来吗？这是虚张声势吗？他是因为被玛格丽特嘲讽而暴怒吗？不得而知。但无论如何，他和埃德蒙都被杀了。
to take on this threat and he takes his son Edmund, the second son, the Earl of Rutland with him. And they get bottled up in a castle called Sandal outside Wakefield. And they're outnumbered. They know that reinforcements are coming.
Rutland 伯爵被斩首，他们的头颅被挂在约克的城门上，理查的头上还被戴上了一顶纸王冠。是的。他成了巨大嘲弄的对象。在莎士比亚的戏剧中，这出名地成为了一幕充满强烈悲剧色彩的场景。理查用那句著名的台词质问安茹的玛格丽特：“啊，披着女人外皮的老虎之心！”这是莎士比亚在同时代人中最著名的台词之一。人们不断地模仿它、引用它，一次又一次……这在某种程度上衡量了这部戏剧所产生的影响以及他对这一戏剧性场景的刻画。我认为，我认为这就是那种著名的勇士在一个法国女人脚下受辱的概念。但莎士比亚有趣的地方在于，莎士比亚其实相当矛盾，不是吗？因为最终他的同情心是在兰开斯特一边，对吧？因为在《理查三世》中，显然约克家族，最后的约克家族成员是一个极其可怕的恶棍。而亨利七世、亨利·都铎就要登场了。显然，出于显而易见的原因，为了维持现状，莎士比亚想要歌颂都铎王朝。所以玛格丽特……女人是温柔的、温和的、可怜的、死板的、誓言、严厉的、顽固的、铁石心肠的、粗暴的、冷酷无情的。历史上的玛格丽特，在莎士比亚的笔下，一直活到了理查三世统治时期，她就像是一个伴随着自己不幸遭遇在舞台上滑行的合唱队兼复仇女神，发着悲声。
But for some reason, Richard launches a sally out from York. No one knows why this happens, do they? It's a complete shambles, isn't it? Because it's not... The Battle of Waveville is not really like a pitched battle isn't it's like a sort of punch up in a wood or something he kind of staggers out into a yeah it kind of gets mugged yeah uh and various series as to what might have happened you know did he not realize what was happening he was he told that people were coming uh was it braggadaccio? Was he furious at being taunted by Margaret? Don't know. But anyway, he so he and Edmund are both killed.
但无论如何，她都是一个了不起的角色。不管有没有莎士比亚，她都是中世纪历史上最了不起的杰出女性之一，不是吗？她基本上被这个一无是处的废物丈夫给拖累了。是的，她为了自己的儿子而战，她像母狮一样战斗。是的，是的，绝对如此。好吧，我觉得这……头上戴个纸王冠，这绝对是死路一条，但这是一个好故事：“约克理查进行了无效的战斗”。我们休息一下，稍后回来，呃，讲讲另一位……其实是另一位稍微有点没用的统治者。
The Earl of Rutland and they get decapitated and their heads get put over the gates of York and the head of Richard has a paper crown put on it. Yeah. And he becomes the object of great mockery. And in Shakespeare's play, this is famously a scene of great pathos. And Richard confronts Margaret of Anjou with the famous line, Oh, tiger's heart wrapped in a woman's hide, which is one of Shakespeare's most famous lines among his contemporaries. And people kind of you know they parody it and quote it and over and over again um which is uh a kind of measure of the impact that the play had and his portrayal of this dramatic scene and I think it's I think
但我们将进入20世纪。不过是一位圣洁的统治者，对吧？我的意思是，字面意义上圣洁的统治者。好吧，我们会讨论这个。好的，一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余音》。
it's the idea of you know this famous warrior being humbled at the feet of a French woman but the interesting thing with Shakespeare though is that Shakespeare is quite ambivalent, isn't he? Because ultimately his sympathies are with the Lancastrians, aren't they? Because in Richard III, obviously the York, the final Yorkist is a horrendous villain. And Henry VII, Henry Tudor is going to come along. And obviously Shakespeare wants to celebrate the Tudors for obvious reasons because of the sort of status quo. So Margaret, so women are soft, mild, pitiful, inflexible,
这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一丝娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及优先购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
vows, stern, obdurate, flinty, rough, remorseless. And Margaret, historically in Shakespeare, she survives into the reign of Richard III and she's this kind of chorus stroke fury that kind of glides onto the action of the play with her luck operations
欢迎回到《历史余音》。汤姆给我们讲了韦克菲尔德战役以及约克公爵理查的结局。我要讲的是最后一位哈布斯堡皇帝卡尔一世（即查理一世）于 1916 年 12 月 30 日在布达佩斯举行的加冕典礼。所以我们正处于第一次世界大战期间。
moaning. But she's a tremendous character anyway, Shakespeare or no Shakespeare she's one of medieval history's great impressive women isn't she? She's basically lumbered with this dead loss of a husband yeah and she fought and she and well and she does fight fight like a tiger for her son yeah yeah absolutely absolutely well I think that's a so paper crown on head that's a no way to go but it's a good story Richard of York gave battle in vain we shall return after the break uh with another well another slightly useless ruler, actually.
奥地利或奥匈帝国基本上，在人们记忆所及的漫长岁月里，一直笼罩在这位非凡人物的阴影之下——那就是弗兰茨·约瑟夫皇帝，他是一个……络腮胡。这个蓄着络腮胡的绝对是军队纪律、简朴、苦行、服役的象征。他有点……在某些方面，他有点像是19th世纪版本的伊丽莎白二世。所以
But we shall be heading into the 20th century. But a saintly ruler, right? I mean, literally a saintly ruler. Well, we shall discuss this. OK, so we'll see you back. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
每个人都……他从不说废话。这真是一个极好的比喻，我以前从没想过这一点。是的，嗯……他从不……他仅仅凭藉超长的寿数，就赢得了人民的喜爱。他绝对是保守主义、服务精神、爱国主义等等一切的化身。但到目前为止，他大约有140岁了。第一次世界大战已于1914年爆发。奥匈帝国人当然是从对塞尔维亚宣战开始的，以此惩罚他们暗杀弗兰茨·费迪南德。这未必朝对他们有利的方向发展。这完全没有朝对他们有利的方向发展。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
他们在塞尔维亚受辱。就在1916年，他们刚刚遭到俄国人发起的勃鲁西洛夫攻势的重创，这场浩大的攻势夺去了成百上千万奥匈帝国人的生命，几乎将帝国横扫殆尽。所以总的来说，他们非常……进展很不顺利。我应该用德语说，是弗兰茨·约瑟夫。他的家庭遭遇了极其倒霉的一生。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Tom has given us the Battle of Wakefield and the end of Richard, Duke of York. I am going to give us the coronation of the last Habsburg emperor, Karl I, or Charles I, on the 30th of December 1916 in Buda, Budapest. So we're in the First World War.
他的妻子茜茜·伊丽莎白，也就是19世纪那位非常浪漫的戴安娜式人物。多米尼克，如果你没有被新冠击倒，如果你能去科孚岛文学节，你就会听到关于她的一切。因为我们去了，我和迈克尔·泰勒一起去的，他非常出色地顶替了你的位置。我们在那座为她建造的非凡房子里举办了一场活动。天哪。我竟然错过了这个。你确实错过了。所以在关于大流行病的普遍报道中，
And Austria or Austria-Hungary has basically, for as long as anyone can remember, been in the sort of shadow of this extraordinary figure, the Emperor Franz Joseph, who is this... Mutton chops. This mutton chop whiskered, absolute symbol of army discipline, of sobriety of austerity of service he's he's sort of that in some ways he's the sort of 19th century equivalent of edisabeth ii so
我认为这……我的痛苦没有得到充分的……没有被赋予……好吧，现在给你一个机会去。是的。去借题发挥。是的。好吧，无论如何，她被……
everybody kind of he never says anything that's a great comparison i'd never thought of that yeah um he never he's he's just by sheer longevity he has sort of worked his way into the affections of his people. He absolutely incarnates kind of conservatism, service, patriotism, all these kinds of things. But by now he's about 140. And the First World War has broken out in 1914. The Austro-Hungarians have started, of course, by declaring war on Serbia to punish them for the assassination of Franz Ferdinand. It hasn't necessarily developed to their advantage. It has not developed to their advantage at all.
她被一个意大利无政府主义者刺伤了。所以她被谋杀了。他的儿子鲁道夫——弗兰茨·约瑟夫的儿子鲁道夫，在迈耶灵狩猎小屋发生了一起非凡的事件，他在与情妇的一场奇怪的谋杀-自杀协议中自杀了。所以他死了，唯一的儿子死了。于是接下来的继承人将是弗兰茨·费迪南德。
So they've been humiliated in Serbia. They've just, in 1916, been on the receiving end of the Brusilov Offensive by the Russians, this colossal offensive that has killed hundreds and hundreds of thousands of Austro-Hungarians and almost swept the empire away. So they've been generally very, you know, it hasn't gone well. I should say in German, it's Franz Josef. He has had an incredibly unlucky time with his family.
他和他的妻子苏菲被加夫里洛·普林西普由于拐错弯而谋杀了，因为他们的车在萨拉热窝拐错弯的紧要关头抛锚了。所以现在即将继承弗兰茨·约瑟夫的人是个……完全没用的人。我的意思是，我讨厌这么说，我知道我们在新的一年里会有哈布斯堡家族的人上节目……他没用。我们说过，这是一种像亨利六世那样的圣洁方式。没错，就像亨利六世。所以这就是我们的平行对照。
So his wife, Sisi Elizabeth, who's this very romantic sort of Diana figure of the 19th century. Who, Dominic, if you had not been felled by COVID and you'd come to the Corfu Literary Festival, you would have heard all about her. Because we did, I did it with Michael Taylor, who stepped in to your shoes very admirably. We did an event at the house, the extraordinary house on Corfu that was built for her. Oh my word. And I missed out on this. You did miss out. So in the reporting generally of the pandemic,
他以前是大公卡尔，基本上是弗兰茨·约瑟夫一世的曾侄孙。也就是弗兰茨·费迪南德的侄子。他……他多大？他继位时29岁。他从来没真正做过什么大事。他甚至都不是……因为没有人指望他能继位。
I think this, my suffering has not been sufficiently, has not been given. Well, a chance now for you to. Yeah. To milk it. Yeah. Well, anyway, she's been,
他只是个随从般的哈布斯堡贵族。是的。所以他继承了这个处于现代列强巨大冲突中的帝国。他其实并不知道自己在做什么。所以他在布达的马加什教堂加冕，
she was stabbed by an Italian anarchist. So she was murdered. His son, Rudolf, Franz Josef's son, Rudolf, an extraordinary incident at the hunting lodge at Meierling, kills himself in a sort of strange murder-suicide pact with his mistress. So he's dead, his only son. So then the successor is going to be Franz Ferdinand.
汤姆，这是一个你会喜欢的、可以追溯到公元 1000 年的仪式。我喜欢这个。以及第一位匈牙利国王伊什特万一世的加冕礼。我想他们会叫他伊什特万一世。他在这个非常……他获赠了一把圣枪的复制品。
He and his wife, sophie are murdered by like a wrong turning gavrilo princip because their car stalls at the wrong moment going after a wrong turning exactly in sarajevo so now the person who is going to succeed franz joseph is a it's a completely useless i mean i hate to say this i know we've got hapsburg's coming on the program um in the new year he's useless we said, in a saintly way, reminiscent of Henry VI. Right, of Henry VI. So here's our parallel.
好吧，这就是我们要讨论的，因为卡尔——所以在 1916 年，在这个充满坦克的时代，索姆河战役，所有这些事情中，他戴着一顶主要是拜占庭风格的王冠加冕。这个非凡的东西，如果你没见过可以谷歌一下，匈牙利圣冠，它远不止是一顶王冠，
So he was previously the Archduke Karl, and he is basically the great nephew of Franz Joseph I. So the nephew of Franz Ferdinand. And he is, what is he? He's 29 when he succeeds. He's never really done anything very much. He hasn't even been, because no one expected him to succeed.
因为有人说它某种程度上就是匈牙利，它是象征，它是匈牙利本身的法律拟制。但是，多米尼克，不久前我们说过，我们应该试着把伟大的奥托——节目的老朋友——塞进每一集里，虽然我们没能做到。但这里有一个机会，因为，当然，匈牙利人是被伟大的奥托击败的。然后他们不仅臣服于德国的权力，还臣服于基督教信仰，并成为教会的忠实仆人。这就是为什么，我认为他们被授予这顶王冠的原因之一，因为这顶王冠被赋予了某些……关于他们究竟从哪里弄来这顶王冠，存在一些分歧。但有些人认为王冠本身是由拜占庭皇帝米海尔七世赠送的。
He's just a sort of, you know, attendant Habsburg aristocrat. Yeah. So he succeeds to this empire that is in this colossal clash of kind of modern, you know, sort of leviathans. And he doesn't really know what he's doing. So he's crowned in the Matthias church in Buda
现在，我们将在这次圣诞十二日的后续播客中提到他。所以这一切，复杂性真是令人惊叹。这一切都连在一起了，不是吗？是的。它是一种织物。是一幅织锦。历史织锦，历史织锦。上面有这些
in a ritual, Tom, that you will enjoy that goes back to the year 1000. I love that. And the coronation of the first Hungarian king, Stephen I. I think they would call him Istvan I. And he's crowned in this very... He got sent a replica of the Holy Spear.
奇妙的珐琅，王冠上精美的插图，都是在君士坦丁堡制作的。这顶王冠被赠予匈牙利人，
Well, this is what we're going to discuss because Karl, so in 1916, in this world of kind of tanks, the Battle of the Somme, all this stuff, and he is crowned with a crown that is largely Byzantine. So this extraordinary thing, you can Google it if you haven't seen it, the Holy Crown of Hungary, which is much more than just a crown
上面全是用希腊语等文字写的。所以它今天仍然在布达佩斯，你今天依然可以在布达佩斯看到它。现在，关于它最著名的一点是，
because some people say it kind of is Hungary, that it is the symbol, it's the sort of legal personification of Hungary itself. But Dominic, a while back we said we should try and get Otto the Great, friend of the show, into every episode, which we failed to do. But there is an opportunity here because, of course, it's the Hungarians who get defeated by Otto the Great. And then they not only submit to German power, but also to the Christian faith and become devoted servants of the church. And this is why, one of the reasons I think they've been given this crown, because the crown has been given some, there's some disagreement about exactly where they get the crown. But some people think the crown itself is given by the Byzantine Emperor Michael VII.
顶部的十字架是歪的。所以如果你看它，会觉得非常奇特，因为十字架就像比萨斜塔一样倾斜。而且我想自 17 世纪它被撞歪以来一直如此，人们从未试图去修复它，所以它已经变成了一种传统。但人们认为，里面有……是不是有十字架上荆棘冠的一部分？——来自钉十字架事件的荆棘被包含在王冠里？我想
Now, we will be referring to him in a later podcast in this 12 Days of Christmas. So it's all, it's amazing the intricacy. It all joins together, doesn't it? Yeah. It's a fabric. It's a tapestry. Historical tapestry historical tapestry there were these
我们可以安全地说，它非常具有神圣性。非常具有神圣性，你绝对没说错。所以卡尔，这个有点没下巴、平庸无奇的人——并不是对我不敬——他在布达佩斯戴着这顶王冠加冕。他之前已经在维也纳待过了，因为这当然是奥匈帝国的二元君主国。所以他来到了匈牙利部分，在那里加冕。之后有一个盛大的宴会，但他们缩短了时间。由于正处于第一次世界大战期间，而且奥地利举步维艰——挑起这一切的国家现在处境极其糟糕——所以庆祝活动比平时要低调得多。但当然，他也面临着这个庞大的多民族帝国，人们不说同样的语言，军队分崩离析，一切都在瓦解。所以卡尔算是个正派人，他……是一个非常虔诚的天主教徒，他极其严肃地对待自己作为皇帝的责任，并且对奥地利如何熬过第一次世界大战、走向未来有着各种各样的想法。所以他认为，我们需要在奥地利建立一个联邦制的国家，各州享有自治，有点像弗兰茨·费迪南德遇害前想要做的那样。他认为应该赋予克罗地亚人更多的话语权，所以它应该包含某种南斯拉夫元素，这样它就不再仅仅是一个二元君主国。
fantastic enamels beautiful illustrations on the crown which had been made in Constantinople the crown is given to the Hungarians
但所有这些都只是异想天开，因为很明显奥地利人不会赢得战争，帝国也可能无法生存。所以他试探性和平。他总是到处试探性和平。是的，我想他基本上把大部分时间都花在了通过某种中间人向盟友（特别是1917年之后的美国人）发送信息上，基本上是在说：“是的，我们能达成某种协议吗？”但到了这个时候，他对于……对于……对于……嗯，对于兴登堡和鲁登endorff——德国的军事独裁者——来说，只是一个如此卑微的伙伴，以至于奥地利人几乎没有什么自由和腾挪的空间。真的。德国人在战场上基本上掌握着绝对主导权。而且，
it's all written in Greek and stuff so it's still in Budapest today you can still see it I think in Budapest today and now the most famous thing about it
他所做的一切都无关紧要。关于他有趣的一点，汤姆，他的妻子叫……不，波旁-帕尔马的齐塔公主。好名字。我喜欢他的所作所为。关于他有趣的一点，汤姆，你知道他的妻子叫什么名字吗？不。波旁-帕尔马的齐塔公主。好名字。
is that the cross on the top is crooked so if you look at it it looks very peculiar because the cross is all like the leaning tower of pisa and it has been i think since the 17th century when it was knocked and they've never tried to mend it so it's become a kind of tradition but people think that there's all kinds of stuff with is there a bit of the thorn what the crown of thorns um from the crucifixion contained in the crown i think
疯狂的名字，疯狂的女孩。好吧，你知道有多少……她是众多女儿中的第几个，有多少个姐妹？12个。17个。17个。17个，你看，17个。猜猜她是什么时候去世的？
what we can safely say is it's very sacral it's very sacral you're absolutely right so carl who is this sort of slightly chinless nothing of a person without being mean to him um he is crowned in budapest with this he's already been in vienna now because it's of course the dual monarchy of austria-hungary so he's come to the hungarian bit he's crowned there's a big banquet afterwards but they cut cut that short it's much the celebrations are quite muted compared with normal because of course they're in the first world war and austria is really struggling you know the country that started it all is doing very badly but also of course he's got this huge multi-ethnic empire people don't speak the same language the army is split apart it's all falling apart so carl is quite a decent sort of fellow he um is a very devout catholic he takes his responsibilities as
1982年。1989年。还不错。我猜得差不多在正确的范围内。你猜得差不多在正确的范围内，但她非常长寿。所以她和卡尔……她最后去了哪里？嗯，他们最终去了马德拉岛，
emperor terribly seriously and he has various ideas for how austria can survive the first world war go into the the future so he thinks you, we need to have a federal sort of state in Austria with all states, a bit like Franz Ferdinand had wanted to do before he was killed. He thinks the Croats should be given more of a say, so it should have a sort of South Slav element to it, so it's no longer just a dual monarchy.
正如你很快就会发现的。但卡尔在会议室里无能为力，汤姆，但在卧室里却非常有效率，因为他们在10年里生了8个孩子。哇。我的意思是，这真是极其天主教的行为。
But all of this is just kind of fantastical because it's quite obvious that the Austrians are not going to win and the empire's probably not going to survive and so he opens peace feelers he's always out opening peace feelers yeah I think he's basically spends most of his time sending messages via sort of intermediaries to the allies particularly to the Americans uh after 1917 and sort of saying yeah can we do some kind of a deal? But by this point, he's such a junior partner to the, to the, to the, well,
是的，确实如此。所以无论如何，可怜的老卡尔。他在 1918 年 11 月被彻底扫地出门。没有人会在乎他对任何事情的看法。在他父亲这样一个伟大的精神领袖之后，对于可怜的查理来说，与我们现任女王的对比实际上有点不祥。
to Hindenburg and Ludendorff, the military kind of dictators of Germany that, you know, Austrians have so little freedom and maneuver. Really. The Germans basically calling the shots on the, on the battlefield. And,
查理至少接受过……所以他在 1918 年 11 月被扫地出门。奥匈帝国分崩离析。所有组成部分都宣布独立。他基本上被赶了出去，去了瑞士。但很多人不知道的是，他从未真正退位。所以他有点心想：嗯，我某种程度上还是皇帝，所以我还可以试着卷土重来。对吧？在第一次世界大战后的混乱中，
and it's irrelevant what he's doing. Interesting thing about him, Tom, his wife was called. No princess Zita of Bourbon Palmer. Great name. I love what he's doing. Interesting thing about him, Tom, do you know what his wife was called? No. Princess Zita of Bourbon Palmer. Great name.
所以，在1921年，他基本上决定未来在匈牙利，我将回到匈牙利。所以在1921年的复活节星期六，他突然毫无征兆地重新出现在匈牙利。他是否受到了热烈欢迎？并没有。我希望能接管现在。现在管理匈牙利的那个人是一个名叫霍蒂海军上将的人，他曾是一名海军指挥官，嗯……线索就在名字里。嗯，确实在里面，但很多人并不知道奥匈帝国曾拥有海军，汤姆。以的里雅斯特为基地，等等诸如此类。好吧，霍蒂海军上将，他技术上是摄政王，所以你会期望……是的，他会很高兴国王说“好”，但并没有。这就像约克理查一样，他说：“这是个糟糕的主意。”
Crazy name, crazy girl. Well, do you know how many, she's one of how many daughters, how many sisters? 12. 17. 17. 17, look at that, 17. Guess when she died?
这真是惊人的相似。盟军会再次入侵，事实也确实如此，因为罗马尼亚、捷克斯洛伐克——匈牙利的邻国基本上已经说过：“如果哈布斯堡家族再敢回来，我们就会攻击你们。我们恨哈布斯堡家族。我们恨你们。如果哈布斯堡家族回来，我们就会攻击你们。”我希望爱德华·哈布斯堡没有在听这个。所以可怜的老卡尔，
1982. 1989. Not bad. I'm not bad I'm in kind of the right ballpark you're in the right ballpark but she was a tremendously long-lived so she and Carl where did she end up well they went to Madeira eventually
他非常失望。他说他有……这里面有些奇怪的事情。他来的时候没穿大衣。所以，我想是因为他原本指望直接在匈牙利人民热烈的心中安坐下来。
as you'll soon discover but they were Carl was ineffective in the he was ineffective in the conference chamber, Tom, but very effective in the bedroom because they had eight children in 10 years. Wow. I mean, that's very Catholic behavior.
于是他得了可怕的感冒。无论如何，他不得不回瑞士。但百折不挠的汤姆，他又试了一次。他等了几个月，直到秋天，然后又飞了回来。这一次他做好了更充分的准备，并配备了装甲列车。
Yes, it is. So anyway, poor old Carl. He's utterly swept away in November 1918. No one gives a damn what he thinks about anything. After his father, who had been such a great figurehead, I mean, this is a bit ominous, really, the comparison with our current queen, for poor old Charles.
装甲列车一路呼啸向前。他从哪儿弄来的装甲列车？我想他只是到达了一个车站。有些人征用了火车什么的。说实话，我没有深入研究这些细节。这是一个伟大的冒险故事。第二次政变，虽然我本应该多了解一些。但随后他很愚蠢。
Charles, at least, has been trained for... So he's swept away in November 1918. The Austro-Hungarian Empire falls apart. All the constituent bits declare independence. And he basically is kind of kicked out and he goes off to switzerland but what a lot of people don't know is that he never properly abdicated so he sort of thinks well i'm kind of still the emperor so i can still try and come back right and in the chaos after the first world war
他没有直接去首都杀死所有的敌人，他不是一个暴力的人。所以他进展缓慢，在每一个村庄和小村庄都停下来，接受农民的欢呼。是的，农民们挥手致意，他你知道的，他们吻他的手，给他送花之类的。所以这就是……他太慢了。基本上他们到达时，匈牙利政府再次……邻国再次表示：“如果你拥立他，我们就会攻击你们，把你们赶尽杀绝。”所以匈牙利政府集结军队，击退了他那支乌合之众的小军队，并将他驱逐出境。然后他去了马德拉岛，一年后死于心碎。
um so in 1921 he basically decides the future is hungarian i will come back to hungary so on easter saturday 1921 he just suddenly pitches up back in hungary and is he greeted with open arms he's not i'd like to take over now now the fellow who's running hungary is a man called admiral horty who's a who's a former naval commander in the well the clue's in the name well it is in there but a lot of people wouldn't know that austria-hungary had a navy tom out of trieste based out of trieste and all that sort of area well admiral haughty he's technically the regent so he's you would expect yeah he'd be delighted the king says yeah but no it's like richard of york he says this is a terrible idea
非常悲伤，非常悲伤的故事。一个很年轻的人，才 34 岁，却有八个孩子？他在 10 年里生了 8 个孩子。想象一下 34 岁就有 8 个孩子。天哪，我连一个都应付不过来。好吧，不管怎样，但你……我的意思是，你有……你有很多员工，不是吗？嗯，他有员工，是的。不，我不是说你，但你没有，你只有一个。对，完全如此。
it's astonishing parallels. The Allies will invade again, which they will, because Romania, Czechoslovakia, Hungary's neighbours have basically said, if the Habsburgs ever come back, we will attack you. We hate the Habsburgs. We hate you. We will attack you if the Habsburgs come back. I hope Edouard Habsburg isn't listening to this. So poor old Karl,
所以无论如何，这就是他的结局。但每个人都说他是个极了不起的家伙，而且我相信他正在通往圣洁的道路上。他是一位尊者。是的，我查过他。所以他是个极了不起的家伙。而且我相信他正在通往圣洁的道路上。他是一位尊者。是的，我查过他。所以他就像比德一样。
he's very disappointed. He said he has... There's some strange business. He's come with no coat. So, I think because he was expecting to be installed kind of straight away in the warmth of the Hungarian people's hearts.
好吧，我不会撒谎。比德可从未发动过政变。如果我是比德，我会为此生气的。你会觉得自己被贬值了。你就像那种……比德，教会伟大的学者之一。你知道，他一生都在乔纳森·威尔逊的领地上做着一个瑟瑟发抖的修士。不过，他可从未在一场世界大战中领导过一个国家。
So, he catches a dreadful cold. Anyway, he has to go back to Switzerland. But undeterred, Tom. He has another crack. He waits a few months till the autumn and then he flies back in. This time he's a bit more prepared and he has armoured trains.
没有。而这家伙，我的意思是，他左一个右一个地生孩子，还发动政变。是的，但毫无用处。但确实毫无用处，说实话。所以问题随之而来，汤姆：谁更好，约克理查还是奥地利的卡尔一世？嗯，我觉得是卡尔，因为他没有……我的意思是，他没有挑起内战。而且因为他确实得到了那顶王冠。
And the armoured trains kind of shoot along. Where did he get the armoured train from? I think he just arrived at a station. And some people commandeered trains or something. To be honest, I haven't looked into the details of this. It's a great adventure story. Second coup as much as I should have done. But then he's foolish.
我的意思是，他戴着的是顶歪的王冠，而不是纸王冠。而约克理查从未当过国王，还引发了内战。所以我认为他简直是个噩梦。好吧。所以破天荒地，这可能是唯一一 podcast，其中奥匈帝国的卡尔皇帝成为了胜利者。
Instead of going straight to the capital and killing all his enemies, he's not a violent man. So he proceeds slowly, stopping at every kind of village in Hamlet to receive the acclamation of the peasants yeah the peasants wave and he you know they kiss his hand and give him flowers and stuff uh so that's he's too slow so basically they arrive and the hungarian government again have again neighbors basically say if you install him we will attack you and kill you all so the hungarian government raises troops sees off his small ragtag army and they kick him out and off he goes to madeira where he dies of a broken heart
是的，我为他高兴。我为这小伙子感到高兴。所以，是的，在他发动政变未能保住匈牙利王冠 100 年后，他赢得了《历史余音》听众心中的王冠。红心K。
a year later very sad very sad story very young man but 34 with how many kids eight kids he's had eight kids in 10 years imagine being 34 and having eight children yeah god almighty I can't cope with one well anyway but you you've got I mean you've got plenty of you've got staff haven't you well he's got stuff yeah no I'm not saying you but you haven't you've only had one no exactly so
人们心中的红心K。你知道我们明天要做谁吗？第一任博卡萨皇帝。我喜欢皇帝，在这个播客里我全心全意关注皇帝。中非帝国的博卡萨皇帝。和我们在一起每分钟都充满了欢笑。他是个淘气的男孩，是个坏男孩，是个非常坏男孩。明天会有更多关于他的内容。我们在那儿见。为了恭维他，我们还得了新冠。哦，多么具有节日气氛的庆祝活动啊。我懂的。霍，霍，霍。我们明天见。
anyway so that's the end of him but everybody says he's the most tremendous chap and he's on his way to sainthood I believe he's a venerable yeah I looked him up so he's the most tremendous chap. And he's on his way to sainthood, I believe. He's a venerable. Yeah. I looked him up. So he's like Bede.
再见。感谢收听《历史余音》。想要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告音频以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Well, I'm not going to lie. Bede never launched a coup. If I was Bede, I'd be cross at that. You'd feel devalued. You're like one of these people who... Bede, one of the great scholars of the church. You know, he spent his life as a monk shivering up in Jonathan Wilson land. He never led a country in a world war, though.
好吧，我实话实说。贝德从来没有发动过政变。如果我是贝德，我会对此感到不满。你会觉得自己被低估了。你就像那些……贝德，教会伟大的学者之一。你知道的，他作为一个修士，一生都在约纳逊·威尔逊的极寒之地瑟瑟发抖。不过，他确实从未在世界大战中领导过一个国家。
No. And this guy, I mean, he's having children left, right and centre, launching coups. Yeah, but uselessly. But uselessly, to be fair. So the question, therefore, comes, Tom, who is better, Richard of York or Karl I of Austria? Well, I think Karl, because he didn't, I mean, he didn't launch a civil war. And because he did actually get his hands on the crown.
没有。而这家伙，我的意思是，他到处生孩子，发动政变。是的，但毫无用平。不过说实话，确实毫无用处。所以，汤姆，问题因此来了：谁更好，约克公爵理查还是奥地利的卡尔一世？嗯，我认为是卡尔，因为他没有，我的意思是，他没有发动内战。而且因为他确实得到了王冠。
I mean, he wore his crown with a crooked crown, not a paper crown. Whereas Richard of York never became king and caused the civil war. So I think he was a bit of a nightmare. Okay. So for once, this is probably the only podcast in which the Emperor Karl of Austria-Hungary
我的意思是，他戴王冠时，王冠有点歪，但不是纸做的王冠。而约克公爵理查从未成为国王，还引发了内战。所以我认为他简直是个噩梦。好吧。因此，这是少有的、或许也是唯一一个将奥匈帝国皇帝卡尔
has emerged as a victor. Yeah, I'm glad for him. I'm happy for the lad. So, yeah, 100 years after his failure to secure the crown of Hungary in a coup. He secures the crown of the rest is history, listeners' hearts. The king of hearts.
塑造成胜利者的播客。是的，我为他高兴。我为这小伙子感到高兴。所以，是的，在他通过政变夺取匈牙利王冠失败一百年后。他赢得了《历史余音》听众的心。红心国王。
The king of people's hearts. you know who we're doing tomorrow emperor bakasa the first i love emperors i'm all about emperors on this podcast in the emperor bakasa of the central african empire it's laugh a minute with us he was a naughty boy he was a bad boy he was a very bad boy more on on him tomorrow. We'll see you there. And just to compliment him, we've got the coronavirus. Oh, what a festive celebration. I know. Ho, ho, ho. We'll see you tomorrow.
人民心中的国王。你知道我们明天要讲谁吗？博卡萨一世皇帝。我喜欢皇帝，在这个播客里我最关注皇帝，中非帝国的博卡萨皇帝。和我们在一起每分钟都充满欢笑。他是个调皮的孩子，他是个坏男孩，他是个非常坏的男孩。明天会有更多关于他的内容。我们到时见。为了配合他，我们还有冠状病毒。哦，多么喜庆的节日啊。我知道。嚯，嚯，嚯。我们明天见。
Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《历史余音》。想要获取独家单集、提前收听权限、无广告体验以及我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。